if some magic sorcerer turned your head
into a terrifying lizard what would you
do you've been left for dead and have no
memory of who you are but you will have
to battle sorceress from hell in order
to be able to solve your mystery I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
demons the sorcerers in Doro hidoro this
freak is going to go fight to the death
against an entire realm of terrifying
Sorcerers kaiman here is a human who got
his head magically turned into a lizard
at least that's what he thinks left for
dead she has no memory of who he is or
what he used to look like teaming up
with his best friend nikaido they both
try to find the sorcerer responsible for
turning him into a lizard face and they
go and interrogate these low-level
Sorcerers in a grisly street battle and
kaiman is somehow immune to all magic
and easily beats this sorcerer who I'm
gonna call Pinocchio grabbing his
partner he opens up his terrifying jaw
and clamps his mouth around the
sorcerer's entire skull the man and
tries to escape but can't but then he
hears something and looks and sees a
whole human head creeping up from inside
kyman's throat it's disgusting and this
throat goat guy crosses his eyes and
stares into the sorcerer's Soul he's not
the man that they're looking for common
takes the man out of his mouth and asks
him what did the guy say and he tells
kaimin what the man in his throat said
that he's not the one now useless to
kaiman he kills this guy but not before
somehow this fat-nosed sorcerer sends
his partner away through this magical
door with no more current leads kaimin
and nikaido decide to call it a day and
head back into their City the most
dangerous city in the world this place
is used as a horrifying testing ground
for Sorcerers to test out their powers
on humans and in the wake of this
aftermath they leave behind thousands of
corpses and disfigured humans in their
wake whoa this is nuts this city
centuries ago was discovered by a devil
from another realm and he basically
began using this city as his magical
playground to mess with humans and used
them for his terrifying experiments
using magical doors as portals to enter
and exit this world from theirs kaiman
wants to find out who turned his human
head into a lizard and thinks the
stranger inside his mouth will be able
to identify the sorcerer responsible but
this process of elimination is too slow
and time consuming if I was kind I would
work backwards and focusing on figuring
out who I was as a person first by
trying to identify our past habits it's
noted that this city is trashed to bits
all because of the visiting demons and
Sorcerers this place is a literal hell
hole and everyone here lives in poverty
including us while that sucks the fact
that we're poor could help us identify
who we were before our lizard accident
everyone in this city including us
likely grew up in these poor conditions
since this city has been this way for
years and did you know that exposure to
Poverty especially when young has been
linked with alterations in people's
cortisol levels and reduction in the
brain's Hippocampus a region in your
noggin that is critical for regulating
healthy stress responses which basically
means that since everyone here grew up
pores all get out there's a very good
chance that their brain development came
out a little wacky because of chronic
stress and it's likely that almost every
human in this city has developed habits
that they use to form as a sort of
copingism for stress and stress on
average promotes exacerbating habits
which makes them harder to break meaning
that as kaiman I likely have hundreds of
bad habits embedded within me that I've
been doing for years and I didn't even
know so instead of hunting down the
sorcerers which is good and I will do
that eventually I would work on figuring
out what habits we naturally have and
would begin chasing down any habit that
we naturally feel in that moment this
means that say if I craved a beer for
example I would begin going to different
bars and begin to take note of how each
bar made me feel because it's likely
that as a poor person who loves drinking
and cares around all sorts of bad habits
within me it could be that before my
memory loss I might have gone to one bar
more than the other and have even
ordered the same drink for years by just
asking around and going to places that I
frequent I might be able to learn a bit
more about my past it's slow I will
admit but at the very least we will be
able to start to piece together a
psychological profile of who I was
before I lost my memory kaiman gets
annoyed at himself for letting one of
the sorcerers get away but he doesn't
realize that he'll soon be forced to
battle against the most powerful
Sorcerers and demigods in the universe
the next day he gets a part-time job at
the city's Hospital weird choice but
moving on and it's a place where victims
of magic can try to recover he does his
best to try and gather info from the
patients here about any Sorcerers that
might know who turned his human head
into a lizard but today there are no
patients so kaiman leaves work early
deciding to hit up nikaido's diner for
some food he walks in expecting dinner
but that's when he sees his best friend
being transformed into a bug this
sorcerer tells kaiman that he's almost
done with his magical practice for the
day and he can have his friend back in a
sec common fiercely attacks this guy and
overpowers him and puts him in his mouth
and he quickly figures out that this guy
also can't help him figure out his
identity and he quickly kills him and in
doing so kill kills his 10th sorcerer in
the human world which is a number that
he will soon regret that he just
achieved back in the magical realm a
giant nose guy sorcerer reports back to
the boss of this place called Mr n he
reports that his partner recently got
killed by the man with a lizard head
named kaiman and he reveals that he was
immune to all of their magic attacks Mr
and is surprised finding out that a
human could ever be immune to Magic and
he suspects that this common person must
already have someone else's spell placed
on top of it and this would explain his
strange lizard head and why their spells
don't work on him impressed with
kaiman's magic protection he asks
Pinocchio over here to go find the
sorcerer responsible for placing the
lizard's spell on kaiman and hands him a
computer with a list of all the
sorcerers in the world he looks through
it and recognizes one of the sorcerers
that he passed by the other day and
quickly travels back to the human realm
to find this person the next day kaiman
meets up with a now debugger fight
nikaido again and they both go to pick
up some photos since neither of them can
see what the man inside kaiman's mouth
looks like so they shoved camera down
kyman's throat in hopes that they'll be
able to finally be able to see the
mysterious throat guy picking up the
images from the camera shop they're
about to look at the photos when they
come across a sorcerer as they try to
open a magical door but can't kaiming
confronts the sorcerer and asks if he
can shove this person down his throat
real quick just to quickly resisting
nikaido helps kaiman and they together
manage to finally pull off this
sorcerer's mask and discover that this
terrifying sorcerer is a sweet terrified
little girl kaiman hesitates for a
second but says screw it and Chomps down
on her the man inside camera's throat
comes up again and is about to reveal if
this girl is the sorcerer responsible
for his lizard spell but out of nowhere
Pinocchio appears again and pulls the
little girl into his Magical Door but in
doing so accidentally rips her face off
literally in the process now unable to
ask this new sorcerer any questions and
with no results gathered from the photos
kiman gets sad and decides to drink the
night away later Mr n calls his best
sorcerer bounty hunters to meet shin and
noi and also Pinocchio and this
mysterious girl that he brought along
and he finds out her name is ebisu and
they all have dinner together and Mr n
gives them their next assignment he
tells them about kaiman and nikaido
immune to Magic kaiman has been killing
too many Sorcerers of the last two years
and now he must be stopped fortunately
Mr Anne's best bounty hunters are a
little bored with their easy bounties
recently so Mr n tells shin and noi that
this target might be the strongest one
yet and they get a little bit excited he
also makes noi fix ebisu's face and she
tells him that because of ebisu's
traumatic face accident earlier she now
has PTSD and a little bit of a memory
loss problem but he will come back in
time Mr n tells them that her sorcerer
file says that she knows lizard magic so
if she's not the one who did the spell
she might be able to identify the
sorcerer responsible for putting a spell
on kaiman so they take her along and the
Sorcerer gang heads out to find and kill
kaimin and nikaido the next night the
city back in the human world prepares
for its annual Night of the Living Dead
Festival a night once a year where
victims of magic rise from the dead due
to all the magical pollution in the city
in exchange for the fun prizes the
citizens of the city all join in to stop
these flesh-eating monsters kaiman his
boss Andy kaido all join in to help her
win a meat grinder prize for her
restaurant midnight then finally rolls
around Sirens begin blasting as zombies
begin Rising everyone gets to wear
killing hordes of zombies all over the
place right as Mr ends sorcerer's Squad
finally shows up from the magical realm
and they've realized what they've just
stepped into and are forced to
relaxantly join in on the fight
meanwhile kaiman and ikaido keep on
kicking ass and taking names but take a
quick break they're sipping on some
sweet Ramen when they finally get
discovered by Mr n's team Pinocchio
confirms kaiman's identity for them in
the distance but then he can't help them
anymore because ebisu starts to get
eaten by zombies so he has to go save
her nikaido spots Mr n's team starting
to go towards them and knows that these
strangers are about to kill them she
tells kaiman and the two get ready
kaiman charges in thinking that this
will be a piece of cake but oh it's not
okay we've just run into trouble with
these guys but kaiman here could have
predicted this if I was him I could have
assumed that killing a bunch of
sorcerers over time would have resulted
in a bounty being placed on my head
especially since we as humans are the
lowest level on the totem pole and it
goes in this order folks devil sorcerer
human and we're causing trouble for the
higher-ups also seeing the quality of
masks that these Sorcerers were wearing
already could have told me that fighting
these guys head on might be a big
mistake masks increase a sorcerer's
power the higher quality a mask the
stronger their magic which means that
these guys were very likely strong and
on top of that chin here is cousins to
Mr n which means killing as many
Sorcerers as kaiman did he should have
already known who he was up against if
he did his homework on what types of
sorcerers were out there in the first
place because I'm sure there's a black
book out there in the Underworld that
you could buy to figure out who ranks at
the top of the sorcerer world and in
getting this it would have helped him
figure out which sorcerer turned his
head into a lizard and also could have
prepared him for moments like this
against enemies that could legit kill
him in this case Brute Force head-on is
not the answer but we could use the
zombies around us as a good distraction
being kind in here I would Tony kaido
and this guy wherever he is to round up
hordes of zombies first before leading
them right to where Shin's gang is in
short we'll have three people leading
three different hordes of zombies from
three different directions which means
shin and his crew will be distracted and
this could give us the opportunity to
sneak away or we could take this one
step further and look for a gun while
we're at it allowing nikaido and this
guy with the tattoo to provide an
OverWatch for us while we get up close
and personal with these guys the point
is these guys repeating their head-on
tactics over and over again without
changing it up a little bit is going to
be a recipe for disaster they're gonna
get themselves killed eventually they
battle it out but kaiman quickly
realizes that these guys are the
strongest opponents he's ever fought
nicaido gets beaten down to the ground
as kaiman gets stabbed in the head going
limp causing Shin to lower his guard
surprising the man he Chomps down on his
head and shin sees them and inside of
caiman's mouth and he notices he has
crosses painted over his eyes he quickly
announces that Shin isn't the one just
as Shin manages to sever kaiman's head
from the outside nikaido still
pretending to be dead suddenly gets up
and saves kaiman grabbing his severed
head and his body and she opens up a
magical door revealing to everyone that
she is also a sorcerer too the two
Escape but Shin knows that kaiman isn't
dead and realizes that in order to kill
kaiman they need to find the sorcerer
that cast that spell on him first a few
days later kaiman wakes back up at the
hospital where he works and finds out
that his head has magically grown back
his boss reveals to him that hikaido is
a sorcerer but he laughs it off and says
he's crazy and doesn't believe him later
kaiman hits Up nikaido's Restaurant when
the boss shows up again with kaiman's
Old head and has a crazy idea he wants
to dissect it in order to solve kaiman's
Lizard Head mystery of course back at
the hospital kaiman and crew get to work
but out of nowhere the power shuts off
and kaiman begins tripping ball walls
and sees this stranger the power then
flashes back on but they discovered that
kaiman's severed head is now missing
they quickly checked the cameras but
only spot a shadow and realized that
someone has stolen it now with another
dead end and his lizard mystery still
not solved kaiman begins to lose hope
meanwhile back in the magic realm Mr end
finds out more info from Shin about who
he saw inside of kaiman's mouth he tells
his boss that the man had crosses over
his eyes Mr and then has an idea and
takes everyone to visit a sorcerer
friend of his this sorcerer that has a
literal turkey for a head this sorcerer
is known for making living dolls out of
people once alive these dolls will
imitate the habits of the person they
are based on Shin then describes the
person that he saw inside of caiman's
mouth and this guy brings the image in
Shin's head to light Mr n takes a good
look at the person but doesn't recognize
him and neither does anyone else the
turkey-headed sorcerer then tells them
that this doll will lead them to the
real person with crosses on his eyes as
living dolls tend to head to where the
original person is located soon they
will find the man with crosses on his
eyes and it will allow them to find out
who kaiman really is after that Mr n's
gang follows the doll around town and he
leads them to a run-down apartment and
into this room shin and Noy look around
from the outside while Pinocchio and
ebisu look around inside and they
discover this box but all suddenly
freaks out and badly hurts these two
shin and noi then return and kick its
ass Shin picks up the mystery box and
opens it up to find a rotting severed
head inside noi then uses her magic on
the head to restore it and they find out
that this is the real man with crosses
on his eyes the man inside of caiman's
mouth later they meet back up with Mr n
and he takes them to a special sorcerer
party for corpse lovers here they wait
for a famous sorcerer known for bringing
people back from the dead Mr n says that
this person will be able to bring the
dead head they found back to life and
they also find out that ebisu has been
to this party before but they don't know
why after waiting forever the famous
sorcerer finally arrives and shows off
her powers bringing this dead guy
hanging from the ceiling back to life Mr
n is impressed and wants to make this
sorcerer his partner he tells shin and
Noy that he's been looking for somebody
that can control time but he's never
been able to find one so finding a
necromancer sorcerer who can bring back
the dead will have to do he orders them
to abduct her and they head off ebisu
then runs off into the bathroom but then
runs into somebody that knows her
without her memory she innocently
accepts what the man gives her and tries
some magic powder an addictive substance
that temporarily increases a sorcerer's
Powers this activates ebisu's power
10-fold and she accidentally kills this
man instantly meanwhile shin and Noy
find the Sorcerer And kidnap her killing
her partner in the process Mr n comes in
and realizes that this woman is using
magic powder and is a fake he quickly
kills her and then discovers something
hidden under the woman's dress and
realizes that this is the real sorcerer
that gives life this pig devil Mr n
picks up the pig devil and tells the
group that he couldn't find much info on
kaido sorcerer powers and doesn't know
what type of magic she uses but he tells
them that with this pig devil they'll be
able to bring back the dead guy with
crosses painted over his eyes back to
life and they will be able to find out
more information back in the human City
some months pass by as kaiman and ikaido
get word from his boss that he has a
friend that might be able to help kaiman
solve his lizard face mystery they pay a
visit to the friend sorcerer who is just
a kid and this kid sorcerer tells him
that he's recently created a magical
door himself the first Magical Door made
by humans actual humans not Sorcerers
they don't count and it's made from the
Flesh and Bones of hundreds of sorcerers
this door will be able to take kaiman
and ikaido into the magical realm where
they'll be able to track down the sorcer
responsible for turning his human head
into a lizard putting on this clever
disguise to not get discovered it's not
that great they head through the door
now inside the magical realm kaimin
plans to kill all the sorcerers here one
by one as many as he needs in order to
fight his Target but the smart one
nikaido tells him the that they need to
keep a low profile and only kill in
secret kaiman my man what are you doing
you are way too Reckless he's only going
to get himself killed he isn't in the
human realm anymore this is the magical
realm where Sorcerers live and Devils
watch over it and this means that
nikaido is right about the fact that we
should be way more low-key than we ever
were if I was kind I would think
critically about that situation because
shoving sorcers in our mouth day one
when we just got here is a too time
consuming and B way too conspicuous that
is not low-key at all I would try and
instead not Chomp down on the locals and
instead befriend them go to a bar where
alcohol would be flowing get everyone's
mouth loose and there we could gain
drunk friends and get some info on a
variety of different sources around here
I would first try and find one who could
draw a realistic sketch portraits and
test his skills in the bar first get him
a little buzzed and then meet with him
later in a secluded area then clamp down
on him with my freaking lizard mouth
because by finding someone who could
draw semi-realistic portraits for us we
could be able to physically draw what
the man in our mouth looks like isn't
that a good idea think about it because
just looking for someone with crosses
over their eyes as the sole clue to go
off of is dumb as hell I mean look
around you all these people are freaks
they have tattoos and all sorts of weird
things all over their face we need more
detail and on top of that a lot of these
sources are wearing masks regularly in
public which makes finding our mystery
man that much harder they then decide to
head to the city center hikaido thinks
that they should First Look for the guy
that kaiman saw in the alley before his
head got turned into a lizard they hit a
ride on the Magic Carpet Express kaiman
pulls it quick when clamping his mouth
over the taxi driver finding out that
this isn't the one and he kills him
while there and wrote on the now dead
Wizard's Magic Carpet and they steal his
house keys and continue on meanwhile
back at Mr n's headquarters with the
help of the pig devil the severed head
finally begins to come back to life and
reveals to them his name one of Mr ants
minions then tell him that they've
discovered a gang of sorcerers with the
same crosses on their eyes as this
severed head so Mr Anne tells shin and
noi to go track down this gang and their
leader later in town kaimin title
continue to look for the man that kaiman
saw in the alley but then he gets a
little bit hungry and they stop at the
sorcerer restaurant for dinner nikaido
then goes off to ask Iran for some more
information about this magical City but
then bumps into this devil who hands her
his business card back in the dining
room kymon that heads into the bathroom
but suddenly passes out and sees a
vision about the man in his mouth with
some of his memories coming back to him
he finally remembered the name of the
man in his mouth he wakes up moments
later and runs back out to nikaido who
tells kaiman that she's just spotted
another man leaving the restaurant with
crosses over his eyes just like kaiman
they follow him down this road but lose
his Trail before he enters this building
just as Mr Anne's guys pull up nearby
and head inside the same building going
into this room she didn't know I
confront this mini gang leader and asks
him where the real boss is because they
have some questions to ask but this
lower level gang leader respectably
refuses to talk so shin and noi brutally
kill everyone here a little while later
kaiman and nikaido finally catch up to
their lost lead discovering that all of
these corpses have tattoos over their
eyes just like the man inside of
caiman's throat he tells nikaido that
his memory has started to come back and
they need to find a guy from this gang
named risu kaiman and ikaido then break
into the cab driver's house from earlier
and they stay in his house for the night
the next day hikaido tells kaiman that
they should split up and look for risu
because doing this will be much faster
and they decide that kaiman will look
around this part of town while Nikita
will go deeper into the city she heads
to this sorcerer pawn shop and sells
some of her magic smoke to this guy he
tells her that this is some of the
purest smoke that he's ever seen and she
notices another jar of smoke on the
shelf that belongs to the same sorcerer
she ran into earlier ebisu she kills the
pawn broker and takes back her magic
smoke destroying any evidence of her
powers before leaving with the cash to
meet with an old friend this devil and
he knows everyone in town but she finds
out from him that no one knows who cast
the spell on kaiman disappointed she
asks the location of a man named risu
and the friendly tells her that he's
currently located in Mr n's Fortress she
also finds out a little bit more info
about the cross eyes group and realizes
that they are disgraceful group of
low-level Sorcerers unable to produce
any magic and she wonders how they are
connected to kaiman the devil tells her
that she could solve this mystery easily
if she just use her sorcerer Powers but
she refuses to do this due to some sort
of trouble past and blah blah blah blah
blah and I don't really care stealing
risu from Mr n won't be easy and asks
her why she's doing so much for kaiman
and if she's in love with him and she
says no but probably is and blah blah
blah again not important and this jacked
devil offers to make her a magical door
directly connecting to Mr n's Mansion so
she can sneak in and she accepts his
offer preparing to go in and steal risu
okay nikaido here may think that she's
the that doesn't mean anything
which she's up against people that are
just as powerful if not more powerful
than her or at the Fairly she seems to
be very out of practice with her magic
which means going up against Sorcerers
that train regularly is dangerous as
hell if I her I would first look into
finding out if there were other areas
where we could intercept risu instead
potentially kidnapping him during one of
Mr n's outings into town or somewhere
outside of his compound kidnapping him
in the compound itself is way too risky
and will no doubt come across multiple
security measures add to that we don't
even have any schematics of the base for
where risu is exactly being held captive
and time is one thing that we don't have
on our side once we get in I would watch
over Mr n's headquarters from the
outside start to look for reoccurring
patterns in his outings try to identify
when and if kidnapping reso outside of
the base would ever be possible and
would only consider attacking the base
as a last resort because right now
nikato's plan seems a little bit kinda
I'm gonna figure this out on the go kind
of plan which is really not good
meanwhile back in Mr n's headquarters he
equips risu with a robotic Iron Man body
powered by Magic Smoke and they try to
find out more information about who
killed him his gang and why his face is
in kaiman's mouth they also managed to
bring back one of his gang members back
to life but recent tells everyone that
he still doesn't remember much from his
past but he also tells them that there
are only a few people in his cross-eyes
gang who actually know what their leader
looks like and finding him will not be
easy suddenly alarms go off and they
realize that nikaido has infiltrated
their headquarters shin and Noy go to
stop her they arrive and have a short
battle but nikaido manages to slip away
and continue to look for risu these two
then realize that the magic door that
she came from was made by a devil Mr
en's minions tell them that nikaido said
that she was looking for a man to name
to risu and the cross-eyes's boss back
in risu's locked room risu's Blood and
Guts co-worker reveals something
shocking and tells him that he and him
were killed by one of the members from
his own gang suddenly Mr n and the Gang
quickly enter the room to check on risu
telling him that shit's about to go
south but that's when nikaido comes
crashing in through this window and
violently knocks over Mr n but this
causes him to lose his and he blows
the whole room up with his mushroom
magic and reesu's partner is killed and
everything goes to risu uses this
opportunity to escape from Mr N and
ikaido is forced to retreat without risu
she quickly runs back to meet with
kaiman but she discovers that she has a
giant mushroom growing on her back
thanks to Mr Anne's magical explosion
earlier shocked common quickly takes her
back to the human Dimension and has his
friends save her later kaiman's friend
tells him that they recovered a devil
business card in nikaido's pocket and
tells kaiman that that must mean that
she's a Bonafide sorcerer but kaiman
still doesn't believe him because he's
an idiot they then hear screams coming
from nikaido's room and discovered that
she's been kidnapped kaiman chases after
him and comes across this hallway and
realizes that this is the same hallway
where he was transformed into a lizard
he follows nikaido screams down into the
sewer tunnel but comes across this
terrifying Beetle it attacks him and
quickly overpowers him forcing him to
run like hell he tracks the bad guy to
this door blasting it open he catches
the bad guy and he tells kaiman that he
wanted to steal and sell parts of
nikaido since sorcerer Parts go for a
lot of money nikaido easily overpowers
him and chases out the b Beetle that
followed him as well about to die the
mystery man realizes that he's seen
kaiman before and saw him on that street
when he was a full-on human desperate
for answers he asks the stranger if he
saw who put the lizard spell on him for
the stranger dies before he can say
anything all right common you're a
little bit slow on the uptake here how
has he up until this point not explored
the alley that he was found in at all
that's a little dumb because his
reaction to discovering this sewer tells
me that he never once looked around here
which is really foolish kaiman here has
been trying to find answers to his
Lizard Head mystery for over two years
now but upon the first time waking up he
never bothered to go back to where it
all started he could have found the
answers to most of his questions if he
acted a little bit sooner DNA can last
for as little as 4 hours or as long as a
week on outside surfaces if I was kind I
would have gone back to where we were
found the moment we got discharged from
the hospital I wouldn't have waited two
years to explore it if we had acted in
the beginning and quickly we could have
looked for possible DNA within that area
and could have either found out who else
was present within the area at the time
of our change now because this hallway
area looks to be pretty open we're
probably pressed on time and should have
acted immediately since DNA being
exposed to the elements would have
deteriorated the samples even faster
than normal this alley looks to be a
part of a residential complex and means
that any DNA found would for the most
part have been from the residents of the
building itself or the total number of
DNA samples found would not have been
that high since this walkway area isn't
part of some main public sidewalk it's
not like we're trying to swab and track
down everybody who walked through
Shibuya Crossing by relying on Forensic
Science even in a world full of magic
was a better step than what kaiman was
doing this whole time the next day back
in the magical realm Mr Anne tells
everyone that a smoke pawn shop that he
owned recently got destroyed but his
team found two crazy things in there
they found traces of the sorcerer who
can control time and they found a smoke
sample there left by ebisu analyzing
ebisu sample to figure out what magic
she can do one of Mr Ann's minions
finally arrives to tell them the results
but upon entering the room the minion
suddenly trips and drops ebisu smoke
vile right at the noise face turning her
into a big fat giant lizard meanwhile
sad about kaiman killing his own partner
Pinocchio guy goes off on his own
adventure and goes solo to the human
world and plans to kill kaiman himself
and has ebisu tagging along for no
reason setting up human disguises they
begin to look for climate but they
discover a sign up sheet for a baseball
tournament happening tonight and notice
Common's name on the sign up sheet this
is how they'll kill it they go to meet
and sign up to join the opposing
baseball team that night the baseball
tournament kicks off and Pinocchio
prepares his plans for killing kaiman
but notices something shock his old
partner that kaiman killed but he's now
a zombie and he realizes that kaiman's
team is using his partner as an extra
player for their team like a bunch of
sickos Pinocchio then changes his plans
to kill kaiman and works out how to
bring back his zombie partner knowing
that Mr n's gang will be able to save
him with their magic singing to go up to
bat he quickly sets up a distraction and
uses his shitty magic and he throws a
super fast ball right at her but she
manages to hit it and accidentally
injures one of the players using this
moment Pinocchio grabs his zombie Corps
partner and makes a run for it with
abisoo following close behind and they
managed to escape back into the magical
world nearby noi now a giant lizard
creates havoc in the castle using all of
his strength Shin then manages to subdue
annoy but gets very injured in the
process so Mr Anne then takes both of
them down his secret lift bait with
another Sorcerer of his and his number
one fan this weirdo Chota he's a
sorcerer that has the power to cure
another sorcerer's spells and then
magically cures noi meanwhile
Pinocchio's zombie partner begins to
lose control and he mindlessly attacks
Epi suit which causes her to get pissed
off losing control of her powers and she
turns into a giant blizzard and eats him
and now Pinocchio guy is horrified and
realizes that the person who turned
kaiman into a lizard is ebisu after she
quickly transforms back into a little
girl and reveals that her memories are
starting to come back finally and they
then meet with Mr n in the gang and they
confirm ebisu's Powers saying however
though that her memories are not back
100 later back in the human realm
caiman's memory begins to come back
about his past and he begins to suspect
that the longer he stays in the magical
realm the more he'll start to remember
not wanting for the kaido to ever get
hurt again he secretly goes back to the
magical realm to find risu without her
finding out from some Sorcerers that The
Gang That risu is a part of have
disappeared recently but will probably
show up to the three-day Festival
starting tomorrow night a festival where
Sorcerers can choose their new partners
and where Mr n and his gang will be as
well without money though kaiman Waits
out the festival in this alley hungry
and alone but then notices some bad guys
beating up this waiter kit the owner of
this restaurant Tamba thanks him
offering him food and a place to stay
and even a job at his restaurant the
next night the sorcerer Festival begins
and kyman's co-workers leave the
restaurant to go out ordering kaiman to
go watch the shop but of course you know
kaiman he doesn't listen and heads there
too knocking out these guards and
nabbing a disguise he manages to sneak
in and starts looking for risu on stage
nearby Mr n announces that the three-day
Festival is about to begin and that
everyone here can apply to become the
partner to one of his members heading to
the house of the sorcerer they want to
partner up they must sign the devil's
contract and exchange a piece of their
flesh with their Partners midnight
finally strikes the festival starts and
the contestants go wild however after
the announcement Shin hears an explosion
in a bathroom nearby and discovers that
his partner noi has now gone missing out
of nowhere he almost gets shot by
sleeping darts and realizes that the
people trying to kidnap them a pair of
dudes obsessed with making these two
their Partners cause of well blah blah
blah it's just it's not important and
shin finally gets captured by them
meanwhile kaiman's out looking for risu
and gets discovered by tonba and he is
forced to come clean to them about why
he's really here they feel bad for
kaiman and give him some money for food
but then he bumps into this guy who
makes kaiman drop his food and pisses
him off and Nod realizes that this is an
obsessed dude and is carrying Shin
inside of his bag but all kind cares
about is his food and tries to attack
these guys but gets knocked back Hyman's
boss sees this and his restaurant gang
team up to kill both of these guys and
they leave a sleeping Shin right inside
of this bag all the while his kaiming
gives up hope of ever finding risu he
then heads back to the restaurant okay
good kaiman here has finally found a new
source of stable income and a place to
stay However kaiman trying to spot risu
in a city full of people is like trying
to find Waldo in all of China it's an
all but impossible task if I was kind I
would instead work on getting into the
mind of risu based on what we know risu
is a part of the cross eyes gang but
none of them have been spotted recently
but in order to fund their gang it's
likely that they are still receiving
income through some business of theirs
such as selling drugs in the form of
black smoke and this means that we'll
have a higher chance of finding risu by
finding his gang first by using the
smoke because in this world it seems
that they use black smoke as a form of
currency among other things by tracing
black smoke junkies to their smoke
dealer and following the dealer to their
supplier and so on and so forth we will
be able to figure out the chain of
command and who works for the cross-eyes
gang because if we can get into the mind
of risu it's likely that upon coming
back to life he would eventually try and
locate his old gang since the cross-eyes
gang is more than just a gang it seems
they seem to have some sort of a way of
life kind of a thing going on meanwhile
risu finally arrives at the sorcerer
Festival running out of smoke energy for
his Iron Man suit he tries to fill up
his smoke power in this shop before he
goes to find his ex-gang partner and
best friend but suddenly he runs into
Noy captured in this magic proof Box by
those obsessed dudes freeing her Noy
quickly wakes up and annoyingly uses her
magic on risu transforming his cyber
body back into a human body he quickly
runs away before she notices and now all
normal he heads off to find his ex
partner in order to find out who
murdered him the next day Noe finally
finds Shin sleeping side of this body
bag while Mr n finds some camera footage
at his smoke pawn shop he finds out the
nikaido could be the sorcerer with the
power to control time wanting to capture
her immediately he creates some voodoo
doll and plants a mushroom inside of her
back this causes nikaido back in the
human world to suddenly cry out in pain
and a giant mush rapidly begins growing
right out of her as this happens the
kaido's gang is horrified and the giant
mushroom monster bursts out of her back
and quickly kills this guy forcing the
rest of the group to save nikaido and
hide in her room knowing that they're
about to die the kaido acts fast and
goes into her attic to get her old mask
given to her Years Ago by her devil
friend this mask is able to enhance her
sorcerer powers and she finally breaks
her Rule and uses magic to swiftly kill
this Mushroomhead monster the group
thinks it's over as their shoes get
drenched in the monster's blood but
that's when the blood beneath them turns
into a magical door and everyone here is
forcefully teleported right in front of
Mr Ed he's about to begin his
interrogation with nikaido but they get
a visit from chidaruma the most powerful
devil of all time and the ruler of Hell
Mr n is shocked since he never visits
anyone but chidaruma says he wanted to
give his business card to nikaida
because she's the most impressive
sorcerer that he's ever seen and he
confirms that she can control time and
says that no one in his devil network
has ever heard of her knowing that she
might be the most powerful sorcerer out
there Mr and jumps at his chance and
forcefully makes her his new partner
quickly setting up this new partner
ritual chin and Noy happily renew their
partnership while Anne makes nikaido
swap her flesh with his and the devil
makes them sign it and they both
officially become partners and ikaido
becomes even more obedient to Mr n and
makes her join this kid in this cage to
use her for later elsewhere kaimin wakes
up from a nightmare and goes out for a
breather tanba joins him and confronts
kaiman about why he's really in the
magical realm kymon confesses and Tamba
then agrees to help him find a resuit
and reveal something big telling him
that one of his restaurant customers has
crosses over his eyes and tomorrow he
has a delivery to this very customer the
next day he and kaiman go to see the man
in question discovering that this
cross-eyes gang is about to be executed
and they are delivering his final meal
kaiman wastes no time and puts a clamper
over his big fat head and inside of his
mouth cross eyes guy sees risu and is
shocked he recognizes him he asks kaiman
if they are cross-eyes boss sent them
and is about to reveal who their boss is
but gets executed and sent to Hell
before he can tell kaiman and out of
nowhere this devil the kaido's old
friend shows up and tells them that
nikaido is in the magical realm and is
in danger he then disappears and kaima
gets ready for his new mission to go
save nikaido first Tomba then stops him
for a sec and tells him that they have
plans to go to Mr N's castle tomorrow
anyways to participate in the pie
competition and that Mr and will be
judging at himself meanwhile back in Mr
n's headquarters he brings nikaido in to
speak with the devil King chidoruma and
he tells Mr n that her old sorcerer
masks looks to be the work of someone he
knows and he knows that nikaido must be
friends with that devil later Pinocchio
sits and cries over his dead partner
when he spots that sorcerer kid and his
pet Beetle On The Run realizing that
they've escaped Mr n's prison he tries
to make ebisu stop them but she fails
spectacularly and now the kid's sorcerer
has them dead to right suddenly however
shin and Noy come to rescue him and they
take down the kid's sorcerer but then
Shin recognizes the kid that he realizes
that he was the doctor that saved him
years ago when he was an orphan and blah
blah blah it's really not important Shin
then tells everyone that no one could
kill him or pet Beetle and they all
become friends they even bring back
kaiman's old human boss and the kid
tells them that they want to save
nikaido but Shin tells them it's too
dangerous that they should just head
back to their human Dimension but this
kid manages convention and annoy to let
him save his old friend and it's all
rather cue back in Mr ant's headquarters
Chota calls it nikaido and makes a watch
a documentary about Mr n's life starring
Mr n himself he tells nikaido that as
his partner she'll need to learn
everything about him watching the
documentary she finds out more about Mr
Anne's life story years ago someone
began killing Mr Enz gang of sorcerers
not even shenanoi could defeat him and
this man had crosses on his eyes Mr Anne
went to try and stop him himself using
his magic he thought he killed this
cross-eyed man but afterwards he spotted
that same man escaped through a magical
door without his head and he's never
seen her heard from this guy again then
the real Mr and then enters the room and
reveals to nikaido that he needs her
time controlling powers to help him go
back in time to the day he fought the
mystery cross-eyes man but to kill him
this time for good nikaido deep down
then realizes that this story sounds
almost too familiar to how she met
kaiman the next day kaiman's Restaurant
Group finally sneaks into Mr n's
headquarters to set up their food stall
for the competition but then they spot a
newspaper and sees nikaido on the front
page realizing that she's now become Mr
ant's partner kyun becomes a little bit
sad and thinks that she doesn't need
saving but that's when he spots her in
the distance Mr n and his gang get busy
judging the competition pies so common
uses this opportunity to try and save
her he tries to drag her away but she
resists and tells him that she wants to
stay with Mr n but kaiman tells her to
come with him or else okay I think we
can establish that kaiman rarely does
any research on his enemy or their
capabilities because if he did he could
have figured out that a source were
forcibly partnering up with someone else
met that someone who did the forcing
would have had the ability to greatly
influence or exert control over that
person and would have known that Nikita
would never been able to escape with
kaim in any ways and kaiman would have
also already known this because of the
newspaper that he freaking saw earlier
oh my gosh he's an idiot that would have
told him that she was partnered up with
Mr n kaiman just doesn't pay attention
it's astounding how he misses all the
clues if I was a smart kaiman and
knowing the obvious clues that we found
this could have helped us better prepare
countermeasures and we could have been a
little bit more sneaky and have had a
more secure opportunity to save nikaido
now while we know for sure that she is a
powerful Sorcerer And she is pretty
awesome we've never really seen what
type of magic she can do which means we
don't know how she could fight back if
if we did have to fight her however we
know from observing other sorcerers that
they aren't Invincible meaning they
don't have any sort of spidey sense that
we've come across so far other than just
trained battle instincts so in a way
they are quite human and they can be
taken out or knocked out for a period of
time if properly caught off guard
knowing that nikaido was partnered up as
a sorcerer we can now assume that she is
going to use her powers on us or anybody
said Mr and wants her to which also
means that before we try to kidnap her I
would have asked big brow Tamba if there
was any sort of magic cage or box that
we could have placed nikaido in that
would turn off our powers which I think
is a very realistic possibility because
we are in a world full of magic and the
Absurd is common as hell and also noi
was placed in something similar earlier
and by using this instead of trying to
politely drag nikaido out I would have
just bashed her over the head and
knocked her out as this has already
proven to work elsewhere now with a
human body Reese who returns to his old
gang and gets assigned to deliver a
package he nearly gets killed but that's
when his friend saves him he tells risu
to stop hanging out with his old gang
but risu tells him that this gang is his
only home and he must deliver this
package to the cross-eyes gang
headquarters he thinks the boss will be
there too and there he'll be able to
find out who killed him but his buddy
calls him an idiot for believing in
their mysterious gang leader back at the
pie competition Hikaru tries to attack
kaiman but he refuses to fight her
realizing that she's been brainwashed so
hikaido beats the out of him and
throws him down this hole now very badly
injured kymon tries to hide from nikaido
like a coward but someone else nearly
kills her and sneaks away and now about
to die her devil friend conveniently
manages to arrive in the nick of time
and manages to take out Mr n's partner
contract from inside of her body
meanwhile Chota hears all this racket
and swings by discovering Mr n's
contract he begs them if he can have it
so he can become Mr ant's partner like a
creep so the devil gives it to him but
tells him it doesn't really work that
way and in doing so saves nikato's life
and temporarily freeing her her devil
friend that asks her who tried to kill
her just now but she doesn't know but
realizes that he's still here somewhere
her devil then reveals some more bad
news and tells her that she must either
kill Mr n to void her partnership
contract or she must make chiraruma
cancel the contract himself and tells
her that if Mr n sees her in person the
contract will reappear from inside of
her body so she must run away somewhere
far away where Mr and will never be able
to rescue her or reach her and possibly
wait long enough for the next Blue night
kaiming then comes out of hiding and
Chomps down on nikaido's head and the
man inside of his mouth tells her that
she's not the one again ikaido is
shocked at who she sees and tells kaiman
that the man inside of caiman's mouth is
risu himself he is stunned and thinks
that Riso might be the one who put the
lizard spell on him he finds out from
hikaido's devil friend where risu is and
tells him that he's on the outskirts of
town in this Village but out of nowhere
Mr n enters this area and he's
discovered that his partner is missing
he wearingly calls out dinning kaido but
very quickly the devil friend has a very
very Wicked naughty idea he quickly
transforms Chota into the kaido's Clone
and sends on now a very very happy fake
nikaido to go back to Mr n while he goes
to help the real nikaido and kaiman
Escape they then arrive far away from
the magical City realm on the outskirts
of town they barely escape with their
lives and Freedom the two camp at this
rundown spot where they make plans on
how to find risu finally solve kaiman's
Lizard Head mystery once and for all but
what did you guys think about the video
don't forget to like subscribe leave a
comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how to be
playlist